im badenwürtenbergischen Grünsfeld
herrscht seit Monaten ein großes
Verkehrschaos der Grund gleich vier
bahnübergänge sind hier auf einen Schlag
Defekt die Schranken müssen jetzt von
Sicherheitskräften per Hand betätigt
werden das führt zu ewig langen
Schließungen und immer wieder fehlt das
Personal an den
Schranken dann bleiben sie einfach offen
wenn der Zug kommt wird es richtig laut
und gefährlich manchmal kommen ja auch
zwei ein aus der Richtung einer aus der
Richtung ne also mir ist es ehrlich
gesagt zu gefährlich das ist eine
Katastrophe mir sind Anwohner wir stehen
hier ich stehe hier täglich mindestens
eine halbe Stunde man denkt halt wenn
die Schranke offen ist kann man
rüberfahren dem ist aber nicht so und
dann kann es schon Z gefährlichen
Situation kommen zum Glück ist noch
nichts passiert im Juni versagt die
Technik gleichzeitig an den vier
Bahnübergängen in Grünsfeld die Kabel
haben den Geist aufgegeben deshalb wird
seitdem jeder einzelne Übergang 24
Stunden rund um die die Uhr per Hand
geöffnet und geschlossen die Folge
Wartezeiten bis zu einer halben Stunde
im Rathaus läuft regelmäßig das Telefon
heiß das Problem ist aber nur es gibt
keine Nummer von der Bahn wo man sich wo
man diese Beschwerden loswerden kann
dann ruft man halt bei der Stadt an aber
wir sind da völlig oder uns in die Hände
gebunden wir haben keinerlei
Einflussmöglichkeiten auch nicht darauf
dass immer wieder die schrankenwerte
ausfallen bei offenen Schranken schieben
sich die Züge lautpfeifend über die
Straße bei der Stadt fühlt man sich von
der Bahn nicht ernst genommen wir müssen
dort anmahnen die Bahnübergänge sind
eben wieder nicht besetzt sind offen und
dann erhalten wir auch vielleicht wieder
eine Antwort aus Stuttgart bei der
Deutschen Bahn versucht man erst gar
nicht das Chaos an den Bahnübergängen
schön zu reden schriftlich heißt es
durch erhöhte Krankenstände bei dem
beauftragten Unternehmen können die
Schichten nicht immer besetzt werden wir
bedauern dass es dadurch zu
Lärmbelästigungen kommt und bitten die
Betroffenen um um
Entschuldigung das hilft den Menschen in
Grünsfeld wenig wenn Sie hier rüber
wollen ich sag s ehrlich ich möchte s
nicht abends da einfach fahren und ist
sind kein Schranke da ne ist es schon
gefährlich wenn man dann drüberber fährt
es ist aber eine lächerliche Situation
die wir im Moment haben wir haben eine
whatsappgruppe wo drin steht wer wie
lang wartet an dieser Schranke um nach
Hause zu kommen und ein Ende des Chaos
ist nicht in Sicht die t ist erst fürs
kommende Jahr geplant und wird dann ein
paar Monate dauern